líbano no encuentra salida a su
estancamiento político tras nueve meses
de intentar formar un gobierno el primer
ministro designado del país
saad hariri anunció su renuncia lo hace
después de que el presidente michel aún
rechazara su propuesta de un ejecutivo
formado con 24 especialistas y está
claro que no podremos llegar a un
acuerdo con el presidente en nuestra
reunión le sugerí que se tomara más
tiempo para pensarlo si lo necesitaba
entonces dijo que no podíamos llegar a
un acuerdo por lo tanto me disculpo por
no poder formar un gobierno que dios
ayude al país
hariri fue designado en octubre con la
misión de formar un ejecutivo que
hiciera frente a la crisis económica
social política y sanitaria del país una
situación agudizada tras la mortal
explosión en el puerto de beirut que en
agosto mató a más de 200 personas y
forzó la renuncia del gobierno anterior
la negativa al gabinete será después de
meses de fallidas negociaciones y
bloqueos por la repartición de los
distintos ministerios entre hariri el
político sunita más influyente del
líbano y aún
aliado del grupo chiíta hezbollah la
renuncia del líder sunita podría dejar
al país en el limbo hasta las elecciones
de 2022 y agudizar así su crisis
múltiple con una devaluación de su
moneda local del 90 por ciento el banco
mundial ha descrito la depresión
económica que vive la nación como una de
las más graves de la historia moderna
esta queda entre la espada y la pared ya
que la comunidad internacional ha dicho
que no inyectará dinero al país hasta
que éste tenga un ejecutivo que impulse
profundas reformas anticorrupción